[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
jean pierre raffarin bonjour jean pierre
a faim on est ravi de vous recevoir
sur ce plateau ancien premier ministre
président de la fondation leader pour la
paix merci beaucoup d'être avec nous on
est ensemble pendant un peu plus de
vingt minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
a qui dirige le bureau parisien du
journal ouest france bonjour stéphane
bonjour et on commence jean pierre
raffarin avec la nouvelle de cette nuit
la nouvelle de cette miss et cet accord
de cessez le feu total signé entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan pour mettre
fin au conflit dans la région du nagorny
karabakh une initiative incroyablement
douloureux ce sont les mots du premier
ministre arménien cette nuit en france
on le sait il ya une forte communauté
arménienne est ce que la france aurait
dû s'engager derrière l'arménie est ce
qu'elle a abandonné bon je ne crois pas
qu'elle ait abandonné et notamment son
lien particulier avec l'arménie d'abord
un cessez-le-feu c'est toujours une
bonne nouvelle
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la tension à
l'est de l'europe est tellement
multiples que c'est très important
d'avoir un cessez le feu
il est clair que la france voté aux
côtés de l'arménie parce que dans cette
affaire
l'arménie a beaucoup souffert dans sa
chair mais aussi naturellement dans dans
son indépendance et dans sa propre
puissance et sa propre souveraineté
donc il est important d'avoir une
stratégie de proximité avec l'arménie
aujourd'hui elle assez soutenu l'arménie
la france dans ce conflit pour vous mais
je pense que notre rôle dans cette
partie du monde mais n'est pas suffisant
mais on en reparlera peut-être parce que
c'est vraiment la géopolitique de tout
de tout l'est de l'europe au fond on
voit bien que d'un côté la russie
tout ce qui se passe avec la turquie
tout ce qui est aussi la question de
l'iran on convoite bien que là nous
avons une situation extrêmement instable
et que sur cette partie du monde nous ne
sommes pas suffisamment puissant et
l'europe n'est pas suffisamment
rassembler justement parlez de la
turquie stéphane et d'évoquer la turquie
alors l'europe n'est pas suffisamment
rassembler on entend assez peu sur le
sur le sujet turcs eux qu'est ce que
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire par rapport
notamment à la turquie d'abord je pense
qu'il faut bien se dire que il n'ya pas
d'avenir
dans l'histoire pour la france sans le
franco-allemand est donc sur ce sujet il
faut quand même un vrai débat en
profondeur avec l'allemagne l'allemagne
à un des relations avec l'artp qui est
spécifique dans la mesure où d'abord une
grande partie de sa population qui est
turcophones et donc qu'il y a dans ce
contexte là une nécessité de parler avec
l'allemagne et donc on ne peut pas être
seul en effet face à la turquie il faut
forcément avoir une proximité avec
l'allemagne mais c'est encore un peu
plus complexe trop tard parce que je
pense qu'il faut avoir le soutien de la
russie sur la paix dans son ensemble de
cette région et le prix de la république
a parlé de la nécessité d'avoir une
architecture nouvelle de confiance avec
la russie mais il faut pas faire ce
qu'on a fait avec la chine par exemple
en repoussant poutine dans les bras de
la chine et a aujourd'hui il faut pas
repousser poutine dans les bras d'art
dogan on voit bien qu'il ya des
difficultés entre eux mais il ya quand
même eu des proximités importante donc
nous devons veiller aujourd'hui associés
pour tous ce qu'est notre sécurité à
l'est de l'europe
associer la russie à l'union européenne
mais ça passe quand même par une
stratégie toujours franco allemande que
les français comprennent bien que bien
sûr mais finalement les choses ne sont
pas toujours facile mais qu'il n'ya pas
pour nous de rôle international sans une
proximité avec l'allemagne alors
l'élection de dubaï d'âne aux etats unis
une nature également à changer la donne
oui je pense que il va avoir une
attitude un peu différente sur le plan
de ses relations avec l'europe puisque
ce sur la turquie on va parler de ses
relations avec l'europe mais sur la
turquie est ce que vous pensez que
l'édition de joe biden ça peut modérer
l'activisme de la turquie dans cette
région du monde
moi je pense que ça qu'on met de la
région ce qui est inacceptable pour nous
c'est la situation dans l'otan est donc
là on a bien vu que que trump n'était
pas un ami de l'europe dans cette
affaire d'ailleurs il nous a traités
d'ennemis donc on a un vrai sujet là et
donc on peut pas avoir la turquie qui
traient que l'union européenne et
notamment le président français en étant
alliés de l'otan avaient une stratégie
commune donc il ya un moment ou un autre
il faudrait être très clair sur le temps
et à par rapport à la turquie
ça veut dire que ou où on a une
cohérence de politique on reste ensemble
ou on a pas de cohérence si on se sépare
donc il ya un problème majeur la sueur
de clarification peut exclure et on peut
on peut espérer non je ne dis pas qu'il
faut exclure il faut bien comprendre que
on a on n'a pas intérêt à multiplier les
tensions n'a pas intérêt à faire en
permanence avait dans l'histoire des
choses très mauvaises sont venues de la
turquie notre soyons extrêmement
vigilant sur tout ce qui peut se passer
à l'est de l'europe mais disons
clairement qu'on ne peut pas avoir à
l'intérieur de l'otan ce type de débat
depuis bayonne doit pouvoir clarifier ça
oui est ce qu'il y aura les coudées
franches pour le faire votre avis
je l'espère je ne sais pas on va voir un
retour pour jeudi juste je trouve que
quand même si on si on parle de ces
élections américaines ya quand même des
choses qui sont très intéressants dans
ces élections
1 la politique est capable de mobiliser
c'est pas la fin de la politique comme
on le croyait
après les municipales françaises ont dit
oui à plus de participation électorale
ça n'intéresse plus personne les gens
n'aiment plus la politique la politique
quand on parle des vrais enjeux quand il
ya de vrais enjeux
on voit 150 millions d'américains qui
vont voter un la politique est de retour
2 l'outrance est compatible avec la
démocratie
l'outrance fait 71 millions de voix
c'est à dire que trump fait une
performance à croire
rappelons jamais à nos lunettes
européenne quand l'autre quand on voit
toutes ces gav toutes ces insultes
toutes ses mensonges il a quand même ça
fait sur leur directeur bon ça veut dire
que l'outrance fait partie quand même ce
cette forme qu'on appelle quelquefois de
populisme en face c'est de l'outrance
l'outrance elle est dans la démocratie
et finalement les électeurs en grande
parties l'acceptent
heureusement l'outrance peut être battue
donc n'ayant pas peur ça veut dire que
les extrémistes y compris chez nous on
voit bien que la brutalité et la
violence tout ça augmente dans la vie
politique
les réseaux sociaux nous le montre en
permanence l'outrance peut-être battu
d'haydn le modéré le tempérer l'a
emporté sur le trans donc ça mais sache
également très important et puis
troisième message très important
lakovic fait l'élection et moi je crois
que beaucoup de gens qui s'annonce
candidat aujourd'hui qui se prépare tout
ça devrait bien réfléchir à ça et ce
sera comme ça en france de mon point de
vue lakovic fera l'élection est bien
gérée est ce mal gérée est ce qu'on a
des sécurités pour l'avenir ça ce sera
le sujet essentiel pour le voir ces
salles pour
moi les messages de cette amérique 2020
qui a montré quand même qu'elle était
capable de surmonter ces difficultés une
petite 1,6 rapide qui nous éloigne de la
turquie et de l'amérique mais vous avez
vous avez évoqué la mobilisation la très
forte mobilisation
aux etats unis elle est due aussi au
vote par correspondance qui avait été
abandonné en france en 75 que vous
seriez favorable par exemple à
réintroduire le vote par correspondance
en france je ne suis pas hostile à cette
idée
je pense que les risques de fraude mais
il faut il faut trouver l émoi les
moyens de lutter contre la faute je
pense que ça doit être les technologies
d'aujourd'hui on doit être capable de
gérer ça je pense qu'il faut réfléchir à
ça parce que on voit bien que beaucoup
d'américains ont choisi ce vote c'est
assez amusant d'ailleurs on voit que
monsieur tron conteste ce vote
mais puisqu'il à 70 millions de voix et
puisqu'il n'ya que 50 millions de votes
enfin ça veut dire qu'il a au moins à
mon avis au moins 40 millions 30
millions de voix par correspondance lui
même
donc il en a profité lui aussi je pense
que s'il ya une telle mobilisation il
faut qu'on réfléchisse à ça la
démocratie sans participation est
dangereuse et donc il faut absolument
s'occuper de la participation
ça veut dire ne pas se tromper d'enjeu
ça veut dire que la santé la
préoccupation numéro un des citoyens et
deuxièmement ça veut dire qu'il faut
aller chercher des modes simple de
votation mais on va revenir on va on va
revenir à la police nationale mais juste
sur le message que vous faites passer
certains messages aussi à la droite pour
vous c'est à dire que l'élection
présidentielle va se faire sur la crise
sanitaire a va pas se faire sur la
sécurité abap acer sur le terrorisme je
pense qu'elle peut se faire emporter
oled les choses sur la la sécurité les
dossiers de sécurité sont très
importants et sauf ça va jouer mais je
pense que ça se fera sur la copie sur la
capacité qu'a l'état dans cette
situation de faire exister à la droite
ne vous trompez pas d'élection je pense
qu'il faut faire très attention à cela
si vous voulez les gens qui ont rejoints
mâcon de la droite ce sont des gens qui
sont venus en grande partie pour
l'économie ce sont des gens qui sont
restés à droite veulent et quelquefois
la droite se trompant en accusant ces
gens ils sont restés à droite mais il
estime que grosso modo la politique
économique de mâcon est plutôt une
politique de droite et donc ils ont
cette économie en priorité et
naturellement ils sont très sensibles à
la sécurité est pour le moment le
gouvernement n'a pas donné le sentiment
suffisamment dans le passé que la
sécurité était au niveau de la tante de
ces électeurs là donc c'est un c'est un
sujet la sécurité mais je pense que le
sujet déterminant sera la santé parce
que dans la santé
là évidemment la sécurité et à
l'environnement il ya beaucoup de sujets
qui sont rassemblés dans cette attention
des gens à leur propre santé et surtout
à la santé de leurs proches
et donc il faut bien avoir ça en tête
comment va se terminer ce match contre
la copie est ce que ce sera un succès
pour près d'un maquereau est ce que ce
sera un héros et ses obstacles
on va reparler mais on va refaire un
petit détour du côté de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique et joe biden nous puisque
vous parliez d'union européenne
joe biden lui dit que sa priorité c'est
la relation avec l'allemagne est ce que
vous craignez qu'il ne cherche à diviser
l'union européenne et que ça se fasse au
détriment de la france
bon d'une manière générale ne nous
trompons pas les etats-unis défendent
leurs intérêts donc avec 85 changera pas
avec tram c'est l america first bon et
même c'était l'amérique alone tout seul
bon maintenant je pense qu'il va avoir
une attitude plus ouverte sur ses alliés
néanmoins ce qui a été fait par exemple
sur l'extraterritorialité des lois
américaines c'est à dire imposer aux
entreprises européennes les lois
américaines
si vous avez travaillé avec l'iran vous
pouvez plus travailler avec nous
c'est pour ça que total et psa sont
obligées de fermer leurs usines
françaises en iran c'est inacceptable
pour nous et ça c'était sous obama
donc il faut bien faire attention
bayonne va pas tout nous régler je pense
qu'il a quand même apaiser la situation
et pour nous je crois ce qui est très
important c'est la stratégie
franco-allemande de ce point de vue là
ne nous laissons pas diviser par les
américains nous voyons bien et je trouve
que l'europe a bien réagi là les
discours de madame paul ryan le discours
de thierry breton ont été toujours très
positif souveraineté européenne d'abord
clément bonis des choses très justes
il faut pas qu'on conçoit des petits
enfants qui attendent leur salut des
états unis
c'est notre souveraineté qui doit
compter donc ça faut pas se tromper avec
les états unis mais néanmoins on sait
préférable d'avoir un allié qui nous
reconnaît qu'ils nous respectent et avec
lequel on puisse parler sans être dans
cette situation d'injures et de
brutalité qui était la situation
précédente ce qui peut changer aussi
c'est que joe byden n'hésite pas à
rappeler ses origines irlandaises dans
le dans le
les négociations entre l'union
européenne et la grande bretagne autour
du break site
il peut amener les états unis à avoir
une position très différente et ne plus
être l'allié inconditionnel de boris
johnson comme l'était trump je pense que
c'est très important
un des reproches ça va ça va peser un
des reproches qu'on peut faire à trump
c'est d'avoir choisi le break site
il nous embêtait sur l'iran nous
embêtait sur le temps ils nous embêtent
sur le break site quand il à dire à
londres il faut libérer l'europe lui
faut libérer le royaume uni de ses
chaînes européennes où il faut quand
même de gaulle aurait dit souveraineté
souveraineté indépendance nationale
vive le québec mais est-ce que du coup
vous pensez que joe biden ça peut
pousser boris johnson à faire des
compromis a évité le no deal je ne suis
pas sûr que que ça le fou parce qu'il
est dans ils sont aidés dans un piège
politique il est enfermé dans une
situation vraiment qu est une impasse
pour lui mais là ce qui devient une
impasse pour nous mais elle dit en
faisant confiance à michel barnier pour
essayer d'avoir le meilleur accord
possible et je crois en sa capacité
allez on va revenir sur le plan national
avec les questions de terrorisme
notamment stéphane est ce que vous
estimez que vous évoquez le terrorisme
tout à l'heure en disant que l'électorat
de droite et pas forcément le sentiment
que le gouvernement au président faisait
assez est ce que vous sentez que les
choses sont en train de changer
je pense oui sur quel jeune je donne je
pense que on a peut-être atteint un pic
avec cette tragédie de samuel pâtit
parce que là on a tous nos symboles
réunis et on a eu une douleur qui a été
extraordinairement partager l'école les
enfants et professeurs
7 cette stratégie d'extrême violence
fait qu' il y a un avant il ya un après
sa mère pattie on peut plus samuel bâti
est un héros pour nous de la résistance
comme nos grands héros de la résistance
on a l'occasion de l'anniversaire
général de gaulle on parle beaucoup de
la résistance mais il faut se dire que
ça mais elles pâtissent c'est un
résistant des temps modernes parce qu'il
a défendu l'idée de laïcité est donc
cette question là les pour moi majeure
et je trouve que le président de la
république en posant la question des
frontières va dans la bonne direction et
je crois que on est en train de changer
d'attitude et de remettre en cause
certains consensus politique qui
existait dans la société française poser
la question des frontières s'est posé la
question des migrations s'est donc posé
un certain nombre de questions qui sont
des questions pour lesquelles nous
n'avons pas eu suffisamment de fermeté
dans le passé près est ce que la loi sur
la loi de lutte contre le séparatisme
attendu le 9 décembre penser qu'elle est
de nature à changer les choses également
je pense froid que le parlement sans
doute que l'enrichissent mais je crois
que c'est une bonne une bonne
orientation et que le président du point
de vue là cette proposition était
précédente à cette tragédie de ce mail
pâtit je pense que le président voit
bien les choses aujourd'hui quand il
reparle de la réforme de schengen je
pense qu'il ya aujourd'hui à se poser la
question de notre protection à nos
frontières et aux frontières de l'europe
et donc ça c'est clair que ça passe par
un certain nombre de coopération
européenne mais ça passe aussi par ce
rapprochement stratégique avec
l'allemagne sur tous les sujets
l'allemagne sera plus ouverte qu'elle
n'était dans le passé pour avoir besoin
de nous dans le passé il avait une
petite distance en trouvant que nous
étions part du gestionnaire
extraordinaire et qu'il y avait une
certaine forme de distance aujourd'hui
la question du charbon la transition
écologique la question de l'automobile
la question de la turbie faut que ya un
certain nombre de sujets aujourd'hui y
compris la problématique politique dans
lequel à merkel qui font que l'allemagne
a besoin aussi des autres et elle a
besoin de la france et on est dans cette
période là il faut en profiter pour la
turquie pour les migrations pour le
développement économique pour les
relations et agit pour les relations
avec les états unis mettre une sorte de
stratégie globale partager avec
l'allemagne sur les sujets sensibles
est ce qu'il faudrait aller jusqu'à
adopter d
législation de type une hésitation de
type de guerre s'exonérer des lois de la
paix par exemple comme la comme l'a
suggéré christian estrosi ou c'est ou ça
vous paraît beaucoup trop fort
maintenant je pense qu'il faut et
christian estrosi a raison il faut il
faut se poser un certain nombre de
questions de notre appareil législatif
aujourd'hui lesquels je sais ça je pense
qu'on a parlé de la double peine on a
parlé des peines plancher on a parlé
d'un certain nombre de sujets il faut
renforcer nos renseignements il faut
développer un certain nombre de
contrôles notamment aux frontières
donc je pense que là il faut quand même
regarder notre appareil législatif et
les faire une sorte de diagnostic
aujourd'hui mais là non la double peine
a été supprimée par nicolas sarkozy les
renseignements ils ont été quelque peu
affaiblie par nicolas sarkozy est ce qui
a eu des relations non non il ya eu des
étapes très important l'an dernier car
ils ont réagi et aussi par manuel valls
il ya eu un certain nombre de choses qui
ont été faites j'étais dans cette maison
à cette époque où je me souviens très
bien différentes étapes mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut faire sorte
d'auto dit notre appareil législatif
pour voir ce dont nous avons besoin est
là que notamment nos experts puissent
nous de nous dire exactement lé là où
sont les freins je pense notamment aux
ronds renseignements on a fait des des
étapes importantes sur les questions de
d'écoutés téléphoniques sur un certain
nombre de suivi des fichiers est
notamment donc il ya un certain nombre
de de freins qui existe encore c'est un
sorte de diagnostic législatif à faire
pour voir quels sont les sujets sur
lequel nous avons besoin quitte à
changer la constitution
je crois qu'il faut pas avoir comme
objectif numéro 1 la concision je prends
un coup ce notre appareil législatif
peut être très bien ou compléter d'abord
appliqué et donc il faut pas faire de
l'objectif de la réforme d'inconscient
on l'a fait tellement et je pense qu'il
faut faire attention parce que souvent
quand on fait une réforme de la
constitution ont fait du symbole et les
français ne supportent plus en face du
symbolique qui veulent du concret et de
l'opérationnel sur la crise sanitaire
stéphane alors autre front pour le
gouvernement la crise sanitaire il ya on
a on a une annonce qui apparaît très
prometteuse laboratoire pfizer qui
annonce qui
trouver un vaccin qui fonctionne à 90%
est ce que vous vous y croyez est ce que
vous est ce que vous êtes prudent en la
matière au moins je crois que on avance
vite et que ça on a été sans doute au
niveau international dans une situation
de compétition qui a conduit à une
accélération des des process
scientifique et expérimentaux donc chose
j'y crois je pense que deux sur cette
bataille là je ne sais pas qui la
gagnera et yvan mais je pense que ce qui
est très important c'est que 1 la
science est de mobiliser à fond et que
deux tout le monde cherche une
distribution au fond systématique et
globale et gratuite donc on est on est
sur des divisions qui sont des visions
scène pour faire face à cette pandémie
parce qu'on en sortira qu'avec le vaccin
donc ça je crois que c'est quand même
très important que lier cette nouvelle
et je souhaite qu'on puisse la voir le
plus rapidement mais ce sont des
laboratoires américains et allemands un
kit qui travaillent sur ce vaccin vous
nous dites l'élection présidentielle va
se faire sur la crise sanitaire est ce
que vous dites il ya un risque que la
france soit prise de vitesse sur ce
vaccin qu'elle ne soit pas dans les
premières servies et que ça soit ça se
retourne politiquement contre emmanuel
macron je ne crois pas parce que
justement quand quand vous dites c'est
un laboratoire notamment allemands c'est
une bonne nouvelle qu'ils soient
allemands il faut pas ce qu est allemand
est proche de la france pour partir de
ce principe là il faut négocier ce
principe là et donc je pense que cette
étude c'est une bonne nouvelle
je ne crois pas que nous serons en
position de fragilité quant à la
diffusion du du vaccin
mais ce que je note si vous voulez c'est
que dans la crise de 2008 2010 avec
notamment nicolas sarkozy il y a eu une
coopération internationale on se
souvient de l'initiative de nicolas
sarkozy du g20 présidentielle ils ont
que cette mobilisation qui cadenet une
coopération internationale renforcée là
qu'est ce qu'on a vu dans cette crise
c'est qu'au fond chacun travailler pour
soi on a rétabli les frontières on a un
virus qui passent les frontières et nous
on a eu des politiques nationales la
coopération le multilatéralisme ont
reculé dans cette crise donc il faut
repartir en avant le vaccin est sans
doute une occasion de repartir dans une
coopération internationale mais ne
faisons pas de la compétition des
nationalismes la clé de l'avenir parce
que ça ça conduit aux tensions et
conduit à terme à la guerre info
dépasser les nationalistes pour pour
développer la coopération internationale
et l'om est doit être renforcée plutôt
qu'affaibli un dernier mot sur cette
crise sanitaire puisqu'on imagine vous
avez entendu les débats ici au sénat
notamment lors de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et les sénateurs dire on est
pour cet état d'urgence sanitaire on est
pour ce confinement mais on voulait être
consulté le parlement n'est pas assez
consulté n'est pas assez considéré vous
qui avez été des deux côtés de la
barrière à la fois parlementaire à la
fois premier ministre
quel est votre votre avis sur ce sujet
je pense qu'il faut et il faut renforcer
le dialogue entre l'exécutif et le
parlement c'est clair que sur un certain
nombre de sujets aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas avancer sans le parlement et je
trouve que que quand on est dans
l'action
autant le contrôle parlementaire et est
normal autant je trouve parfois un
certain nombre de procédures y compris
judiciaires qui me paraissent excessifs
quand je vois qu'il y a chez le ministre
de la santé
une perquisition pendant la deuxième
vague sur une enquête sur la première
vague
je n'ai que comment voulez-vous que on
envoie une paire qui sont dans sa
famille tout cela il il est au front il
doit se battre et il ya là une situation
qui est quand même assez préoccupante et
donc il faut quand même pas affaiblir
ceux qu'on envoie au combat pour être
fort et c'est un peu ça notre situation
et dans ce contexte là je crois que
c'est au parlement de faire le travail
que le parlement discute c'est le
parlement mais clie après tout les
débats nécessaires et qui vieillit et
que le droit fonctionne évidemment qu'il
voulait pour que mais dans l'action
protégeons ce qui nous bien regarder le
nombre de gens aujourd'hui qui veulent
quitter la politique
la difficulté qu'ont à avoir des
professionnels en politique tout ça
c'est quand même un sujet majeur
il faut défendre cette action politique
est une action responsable éthique de
conviction bien sûr éthique de
responsabilité ce qui est la
caractéristique du parlement et
notamment du sénat c'est qu'on y a des
convictions mais on y assument des
responsabilités et le temps que c'est un
partenaire pour l'état vous êtes en
train de nous dire qu'il ya pas
suffisamment de sentiment d'union
nationale dans cette crise les
oppositions sont pas à la hauteur pour
vous je pense trop dur
avec mes amis de la droite et du centre
je pense que ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui
dire aux français c'est à avoir de la
lisibilité sur l'avenir et donc dire aux
français ce que peuvent être les deux
ans qui sont devant nous parce que ce
virus il est là pour un certain temps
etc avant qu'on ait une diffusion
complète du vaccin ans mais il va
falloir du temps donc on a le lac au
vide avec la crise sanitaire puis on va
avoir toutes les autres crises
il va falloir rembourser tous les
emprunts qui ont été engagées il va il
va falloir et aider les entreprises à se
développer ou son nous de nos
partenariats technologiques senti sur le
plan international comme sur le panneau
où en sommes-nous notamment dans cette
guerre etats unis chine qui va continuer
parce que cette guerre froide elle va
continuer parce que c'est le numéro 1
qui n'accepte pas la montée du numéro
deux et numéro 2 qui prendrait bien en
place du numéro un donc ça ça va rester
quel que soit le choix de bayonne pour
pour l'avenir donc dans ce contexte là
il est très important que nous puissions
avoir une visibilité et je crois que
c'est pas en attaquant le gouvernement
sur tous les points que on abandonne
cette visibilité donc j'ai vu que bruno
retailleau a fait une lettre vrai je
pense que c'est ce type de démarche qui
est de donner de la lisibilité de la
profondeur comment gère-t-on l'ailé les
deux ans à peu près qui sont devant nous
tirant jambon est la campagne
présidentielle et voyons non seulement
l'aspect sanitaire
l'aspect économique et financier
l'aspect personnel psychologie
territoriales vous avez vu quand même
que les territoires sont vraiment
concerné dans cette affaire cette crise
est d'abord une crise quand même des
métropoles
donc il faut il faut voir c'est ce que
j'ai dit m'a frappé dans ces élections
américaines notamment c'est cette carte
quand on voyait tout la carte comté par
comté les rouges républicain les bleus
fracturé les montagnes et dont il ya une
fracture ville campagne et non et vous
avez des petits points bleus tout hisser
les bleus qui gagne miyako des petits
pois bleus mais tout le reste est rouge
ça veut dire que le territoire
aujourd'hui globalement les kilomètres
carrés vote républicain et les villes
les têtes de vis dans votre démocratie
qu'il nous reste malheureusement dans
peu de temps non mais oh non non non je
parle tout le temps mais malheureusement
il nous en reste peu un mot sur la
décentralisation puisque c'est vous qui
est le père d'une des dernières grandes
lois de la dernière grande loi
décentralisatrice il ya une loi 3d qui
en préparation mais un mot peut-être sur
le rsa le rsa qui va être renationalisée
en tout cas l'état est prêt à prendre en
charge le versement du rsa en
seine-saint-denis parce qu'il ya trop de
difficultés sociales
c'est vous qui avez confié le
financement du rsa ou département est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous dit
c'était une erreur il faut leur
nationaliser partout non c'était pas une
erreur parce qu'on voulait que
département améliore la gestion de
l'état qui était très bureaucratique ce
qui n'est pas acceptable c'est que
l'état décide et fasse payer aux autres
ça ça me révolte c'est cette conception
de la décentralisation
même quand on parle du couple préférait
ont fait hommage au partenariat
heureusement qu'en partie quand qu'il ya
un partenariat mais la décentralisation
c'est pas le partenariat la
décentralisation c'est des libertés en
échange de responsabilités on vous
confie une politique et vous mener la
politique c'est à dire le département et
fixe les règles de la rs1 du rsa et ils
appliquent leurs essaims aujourd'hui
l'état fixe les règles et fait payer aux
autres ça c'est pas possible ce n'est
pas de la décentralisation s'est fait
refaire aux collectivités son propre
travail la décentralisation
ce sont des libertés et d'avoir la
capacité de traiter aujourd'hui qu'on
donne l'emploi la responsabilité de
l'emploi aux régions qu'on donne le
tourisme département compte des
responsabilités de sécurité aux maires
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il faut
donner des responsabilités avec des
libertés mais voyez par exemple il ya
plus d'impôts locaux vraiment qu'ils
sont décidés par le territoire
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il n'ya plus
de 100 viols impôts c'est au fond une
forme de sanction que le lecteur peut
attribuer tu me fais payer trop d'impôts
je vois de plus pour toi c'est ça la
responsabilité et une dernière question
rapidement stéphanois en gros vous êtes
100% d'accord avec françois baroin quand
ils disent qu'ils payent des sites qui
décident paye bien sûr bien sûr mais
c'est un grand principe de la cinq
grands principes de la décentralisation
dans cette crise d'une manière générale
est ce que vous diriez que le le lien
avec les territoires et les élus locaux
en est
va être renforcé où il est abîmée à
votre avis au challenge je pense que le
premier ministre est conscient de ce
problème je pense que ils vont tous
faire des efforts si vous voulez - dans
cette affaire je trouve que grosso modo
nos autorités sont à la hauteur
que ce soit les autorités locales ou les
autorités nationales dont et dans cette
bataille là je ne veux pas m'attaquer
aux combattants nous nous jugerons après
nous voterons après on verra si on peut
avoir un jugement positif ou négatif sur
ça mais tant que le match n'est pas fini
on connaît pas le résultat du match
donc aujourd'hui battons-nous dans cette
affaire et essayons de gagner le match
entre le virus et merci beaucoup merci
jean pierre raffarin merci à nos
attentes merci merci stéphane on regarde
la une de ouest france où stocker le gaz
carbonique que c'est la question à la
une de ouest france merci beaucoup
d'être venu on passe sous tito club les
territoires
[Musique]